>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C
>> Nicholas A. Brown: We're very
pleased to have you this evening
for a special talk
which is well time
for Valentine's Day this
weekend and if you're skeptical
about Valentine's Day,
that's fine too,
it's going to provide a very
simulating intellectual experience
to learn about the
history of something
that we've often put
into a kitsch category.
So we're very pleased to have
with us today Musician
and Scholar, Ted Gioia.
Ted has published nine nonfiction
books related to various topics
in music and he's most known
for his writing on jazz.
His recently released book is called
"Love songs, the Hidden History,"
published by Oxford
University Press,
the Dallas Morning News
puts forth that Ted is one
of the Outstanding Music Historians
in America which is a very bold
and fitting statement for his work.
He has served on the faculty of
Stanford University and written
for many publications both digital
and print including the
New York Times, L.A. Times,
Wall Street Journal, The Atlantic
and he's currently a
columnist for The Daily Beast.
His major work that has sold
over a hundred thousand copies
is called The History of Jazz
and it is one of the foremost,
if not the foremost survey
of jazz that exist in print.
Luckily enough this evening,
Ted is going to sign some books
for us all if we're interested.
We have for sale over there Love
Songs and the History of Jazz,
History of Jazz is
available for $18 discounted
and Love Songs is available for $27.
Ted has a wonderful
and varied background
as you can see in his extensive Bio.
He's also accomplished as a
performer and has several recordings
and he also has a new book coming
out soon called "How to listen
to Jazz" which will be
released this Spring,
without further ado, Ted Gioia
[ Applause ]
>> Ted Gioia: Good evening,
thank you for coming out on
such a chilly night, as Nick
said, I've done many things
but my primary vocation
is music historian.
And as a music historian,
my responsibility is
to ask the big questions on music.
So I'd like to start tonight
by asking what I think
might be the biggest of all.
And it's a simple one.
Can music change your life?
Can songs change your life?
Or let me raise it to a
slightly higher level.
Could music change the
life of the community?
Or let me raise it to
a still higher level,
could music change the
life of a whole society?
And if I put this question in
the biggest, broadest terms,
it's can music change
the course of history?
Now I think that's an
important question,
but it's not a question
we're familiar with.
We rarely hear people ask this kind
of question, even music scholars.
And I think there's
a reason for that.
In our society we tend to view
music as mere entertainment.
It's a diversion, it's a past time.
It's something we do when
we want to escape from life.
We don't look at music
to change our life.
We more often look at music
to get away from life.
It's something we do
after the responsibilities
of the days are done.
But if you push that
view to an extreme,
you get to some strange endpoints.
For example, there's a professor
at Harvard Steven Pinker,
a very eminent professor and what
he says is that the sole purpose
of music is to stimulate the
brain, brain stimulation.
In fact, he calls music
auditory cheese cake.
That's his term, auditory
cheese cake.
And he says that listening to
music is essentially no different
than drinking a martini or
playing a video game or to cite one
of his specific examples
choosing recreational drugs,
recreational drugs.
And I think a lot of us are uneasy
about that kind of comparison.
I think those of us who
really care about music,
those of us who have devoted our
lifetime to music we're uneasy
with the idea that there's
no essential difference
between a Beethoven Symphony and
say a line of cocaine or LSV,
and we just-- something about
that doesn't feel right.
And I disagree with
Steven Pinker on this
but I do believe he has
captured the zeitgeist.
I believe he has captured the
way music is perceived nowadays
in most cultures.
Music is not something of
transcendent importance,
it's just entertainment,
it's just diversion.
But as soon as you walk away
from contemporary culture,
and you take a bigger view, if
you take a larger view of music,
you'll see something very different.
You find a very different
attitude towards music.
I would like to quote an individual
named James Chalmers [assumed
spelling], he was a missionary that
many years ago lived in New Guinea.
And while he was there,
he was trying to document
the local culture.
And he was talking to one
of the musical performers,
a drummer of the Motu tribe,
asking about the music.
And the drummer said
something to him I like.
He said, "The drums are
never beaten uselessly.
The drums are always
played with a purpose.
No dance is ever danced uselessly.
Every dance has its purpose".
Now this is a very different view
from the auditory cheese
cake view, no?
And if you look at other traditional
cultures, traditional societies,
you see the same thing, no matter
where you are, whether you walk
to South America, Asia, Africa.
You take for example
Native American culture.
I often turn to the works of
three female ethnomusicologist,
who wrote extensively about Native
American music, Natalie Curtis,
Alice Fletcher and a woman who
is a particular hero of mine,
Frances Densmore who
devoted decades of her life
to documenting Native
American music.
And at home, I've got a
whole shelf of her books.
And it's sad to say every one
of these books is out of print.
Every one of these books
is out of print, just sad.
But she went over period
of years from community
to community documenting songs
that she saw were disappearing.
And she wanted to document
them before they disappear.
And over the course of her life,
she probably documented
thousands of songs.
And every one of them
had its purpose.
Some of these songs
helped the crops grow.
Some of the songs prepared
warriors to go into battle.
Some of the songs were
involved in healing.
Some of the songs preserved
tribal war,
or used to educate
the next generation.
Some of the songs were involved
in courtship and marriage.
But every song had its purpose.
Every song had its meaning.
And if you look at other traditional
cultures in music in most times
and places, you see the same thing.
You see exactly the same thing.
And I know that most of us nowadays,
we feel that we're too sophisticated
for this, we're too sophisticated
to believe that music heals the sick
or that music helps the crops grow.
But speaking on the basis
of a person who has looked
at these issues for almost
25 years, I can tell you,
you might be surprised at
the scientific evidence.
You might be surprised.
You know, a couple of years
ago, my son was is in 8th grade
and he had to do a science project.
And I don't know about what
it's like here but where I am,
science projects usually involve the
parents, the parents are the ones
that are doing a lot of
these science projects.
So I said to him, why don't you
see if music helps a plant grow?
So we set up two plants.
We had plant A, plant B and
one the plants got music.
I think it was Glenn Gould
playing the Goldberg Variations.
The other plant got no music.
And surprise, surprise, the
plant that got music grew more.
But it's not really surprising
because there's been a huge amount
of scientific evidence that
has studied exactly this.
Plants like music.
They actually have
musical preferences.
Sometimes they will lean towards
certain music or they'll lean,
like heavy metal music, they
will lean away against you know,
but some songs they
will lean towards.
And if you move the speakers,
the plant will change
the direction it grows.
So maybe, music does help the plants
grow or does music heal the sick?
I know we think we're above those
superstations but once again,
you might be surprised
at the evidence,
for example Dr. Barry Bittman did a
study a few years ago and he found
that just playing the
drums in a drumming circle
for 10 minutes changes
your body chemistry,
your immune system strengthened,
the white blood cell count goes up,
the body chemistry
changes completely,
just playing the drums
for 10 minutes.
Now, I'd like to say that music
is technology for cultures
that don't have semi-conductors
and rocketships.
Music is the first technology.
And if I had time, I could give
you hundreds of examples of music
as technology, solving
problems for cultures.
And even if we go back to
the heart of Western Culture,
if we go back to the origins
of western culture,
we see the same thing.
Now let's go back to Aristotle,
you can't get much more
old school than Aristotle.
Aristotle wrote a book
called "The Politics".
This is one of the two foundational
books in political science.
If you study ancient
political science,
you'll read "Plato's Republic"
and Aristotle's "Politics".
And in Aristotle's "Politics",
he talks at length about music.
Now that's surprising
to begin with, isn't it?
That in a book in politics,
Aristotle will write about music.
And you wouldn't see that nowadays.
You wouldn't tune into
these candidate debates,
these interminable
candidate debates.
And hear them talking about music.
You wouldn't tune in to
CNN on election night
and hear them talking about songs.
But Aristotle thought that
politics and music went together.
And for a very good reason,
he thought that music was one
of the four planks of a good
education to prepare people
to participate in society.
They were verbal skills
in rhetoric, gymnastics
and athletics, visual
arts and music.
Aristotle thought those were
the four planks of education.
And he writes at the link
why music is so important.
And it gives us reasons.
So I think these are
important to consider.
He says first of all, that
music instills virtue in people,
he says music built our character.
He says music makes work less
toilsome with the worker.
Music uplifts our spirits.
He goes on and on and then at
the very end, at the very end
of his list, he says and
yes it is entertaining.
But this is at the end so
you can see for Aristotle,
this is almost the least important
thing, the entertainment value.
All these other things
are more important.
And if I had to describe my
vocation as a music historian,
I would say I have tried to take
Aristotle seriously because I think
in society today, we have
flip-flopped Aristotle.
All these other things
we've forgotten about.
We know that music is entertaining
and there's a whole
entertainment industry,
multibillion-dollar
entertainment industry
that controls how we
think about music.
But it misses all these
other factors.
It misses them.
Even the word Aristotle uses
sounds strange to us now.
When is the last time you're
in a conversation with somebody
and you used the word virtue.
When is the last time you were
in a conversation with somebody
that uses the word character?
Those words have disappeared
from our discourse.
But that's a-- that's
a different talk.
That's a subject for a different
day, I'll just talk about music now.
So I've tried to take Aristotle
seriously and I've tried to focus
on the way music has these ardor
power, these transcending powers,
because I believe music is a
source of enchantment in our life.
I believe music is a
source of transformation.
I believe music is a change agent.
It changes things.
And I can still remember
when I first got this notion.
I can still remember when
I first got this notion.
This was sort of a turning
point for me as a music writer.
And this happened many years ago.
And it was due to a person who
really changed my mind about music.
It was a person I never
met, a person I never met.
His name Arthur Danto
[assumed spelling].
And Arthur Danto was
an interesting fellow.
He had two careers,
two separate careers.
On the one hand, he
was a philosopher,
a very good philosopher.
He taught philosophy
at Columbia University.
He was one of the great
philosophers of this generation.
But in his 60's, he
embarked on a new career.
He decided he wanted
to be an art critic.
So at the age of 63, Arthur Danto, a
famous philosopher, started writing
about painting sculpture.
He visit art galleries,
he'd write an art
for the Nation and
other periodicals.
So very and he's a very
good art critics then.
And when he wrote about art, it was
with a sophistication and a depth
of understanding you
rarely encounter in critics.
And I think it's because
he had this large amount
of philosophical thinking
in his head.
And he wrote an essay
at the end of the 1980s.
So we're just going
back some time here.
That really shook me out.
The essay was about the
end of the history of art.
And Danto was saying the history
of art was coming to an end,
which is a strange thing to say.
And I'm reading this now, what
does he mean that the history
of art is coming to an end?
Is he saying that people aren't
going to paint pictures anymore?
No, he's not saying that.
Is he saying that all the good
paintings have already been painted,
that there are no more
good paintings to paint?
No, he's not saying that either.
What he is saying is that art
as a historical progression,
is going away.
We have this notion in our minds
that art progresses
almost like a science.
If you look at the words we
used when we talked about art,
some art is avant garde, it's
ahead of everything else.
Some art is progressive.
We have this idea on our head
that art progress like a science.
This idea has been
around roughly 500 years.
If you go back before that, people
didn't believe art progresses.
If you go into the medieval times,
and you ask an expert about art,
and there were not
many experts on art
but maybe some monk doing some
illuminated manuscript or whatever.
They would say art
is not progressing.
Art was better back
in the old times.
We're trying to preserve
what happened
in Ancient Rome and Ancient Greece.
There was no idea that
art progressed.
But in the Renaissance,
things started to change.
And the person who changed our view
on art is a fellow named Giorgio
Vasari who was an art historian.
He was writing about
Renaissance art and he saw
that things now were
progressing, and he isolated
on a painter named Cimabue,
who we thought was the person
who really broke away from
the constrains of medieval art
and started making
painting more realistic.
And then the next generation came,
there was a painter name Giotto
and Giotto took what Cimabue have
done and added new techniques
and passed these onto
Posteres [assumed spelling],
and then you get Massaggio [assumed
spelling] who brings in new elements
of perspective, new
mathematical findings.
And you see arts is progressing,
and then Leonardo da Vinci comes
with a golden triangle
and step by step,
every generation, the
art progresses.
And the same thing, you could say
it was happening in music as well.
It's no exaggeration to say
that Mozart took what he learned
from Haydn and added new techniques,
almost like if sciences would
have no findings and passed it
on to the next generation, and then
Beethoven took from Mozart and added
to it and Moeller took from
Beethoven an added to it.
And art, it looked like for
about 500 years progressed,
but what Danto said is this all
stopped in the 1950s and 1960s.
Art stopped progressing.
He was looking at Andy Warhol
and you see Warhol was painting
pictures of Campbell's Soup cans.
So you can't say this is
progressing over Jackson Pollock,
you know Jackson Pollock a
few years earlier was doing
abstract expression.
He was actually taking cans of
paint and throwing it on canvasses.
Well you can't say the soup
can is progressing from that.
You can't say that Jackson
Pollock is progressing
from Salvador Dali's surrealism.
I mean, art is changing but
it's changing the way the
weather changes.
There's no more progress in art.
And the same thing is true
in music he would claim.
You can't say John Cage is building
on the foundations if
you're in Copeland.
You can't say that
Philip Glass is building
on the foundations of John Cage.
And so what Danto said is the
history of art as a progression,
stopped in the 1950s and 1960s.
There's no more progress in art.
It might fluctuate the way
fashions out of Paris fluctuate.
But there's no more progress.
And then Danto said the
thing that shook me up.
He said, "What do you do
now if you're an artist?"
If you're an artist
nowadays, what do you do?
He said well art has to go back
to what has always been
its primary purpose.
Art has to go back to what has
always been its primary purpose.
You're wondering what
is, what is this?
What has always-- What is art?
He says, art has to go back
to fulfilling human needs.
Art has to meet human needs.
Now I'm reading this back in 1989.
I was a much younger man then.
And I really have no idea
what he is talking about.
You know, I'm trying to learn
to be a jazz pianist then,
so I'm practicing how to play "I
Got Rhythm" changes on all 12 keys.
Now what human needs,
am I needing doing that?
I turn on the radio and
there's a Beatles song,
you know what, human
needs being met.
And I thought that Arthur
Danto was a smart guy
but I have no clue what
he is talking about here.
But you know over the
next few years,
as I researched music more
deeply, as I researched the history
of music more deeply, I understood
that Danto in fact was correct,
that Danto was right that
in most times and places,
musicians are not trying
to be scientist,
they're not trying
to create progress.
They're integrated in the
life of their community.
They are meeting human
beings on a daily basis.
And then I began asking
myself this question.
What would the history of
music look like if we wrote it
from the perspective of human needs?
What will the history of
music look like if we wrote it
from the perspective of everyday,
people and how music entered
their life and changes their life,
you could just-- most music
history just focuses on Superstars.
Most music history is
just about somebody
who wrote a work of
music for the king.
I was hired by the Pope to write
a work or it's about somebody
who plays at Carnegie Hall, or maybe
it's about a rock band that plays
on a foot ball stadium in front of
a hundred thousand screaming fans,
but that's just a tiny
slice of our musical lives.
That's just a tiny slice
of our musical lives.
You know, if we write music
history from that perspective,
we miss most of what
music is all about.
And so I've started saying
could I write music history
in a different way that
captures what really happens
in people's lives?
And so I can see the
first glimmerings of this,
I can see my own journal started
in 1991, it was 25 years ago.
I began studying and researching how
music changed the lives of people
in different societies,
different historical periods.
And it was difficult,
it was complex.
I was immersing myself
into all sorts of research
that normally musical historians
don't look at from ancient history,
anthropology, folklore,
mythology, et cetera, et cetera.
And gradually I began putting
together specific studies,
isolating specific strands
of our musical lives.
And this first came to
fruition 10 years ago,
I published two books
on the same day.
And also that is something
I will never do again,
try to publish two
books on the same day.
That is just too hard.
But one was called work songs.
It was the history of
music as it relates
to human labor throughout history.
Then I wrote a second book called
"Healing Songs" about the role
of music in wellness and health.
Once again throughout all
of human history starting
from pre-historic times
to present day.
And I published these and at that
point I said to finish this project,
I have to go after
the biggest subject
of them all, which is the love song.
The love song, because if
you take seriously the notion
that music can change
people's lives, you really have
to look at the love song.
You know at the very beginning
of my talk, I asked you,
can a song change your mind?
And I bet a lot of you
thought about love songs.
I bet a lot of you thought about
love songs because that's a song
that has changed many
people's lives.
You know, my younger
brother is a DJ.
Actually he said many careers
that he's pursued over the years,
we have one thing in
common, anything he does
for job involves going to a party.
So he's been like a bartender.
He was a rapper.
He would run casino nights, but
for the most part, he was a DJ
and he would play music
at gatherings.
And he would tell me
when you provide music
at a wedding reception, the
most important thing is to go
to the couple and say
"What is your Song?"
What is your song because
every couple has a song.
It's some song that brought them
together and if you are going
to be providing music at
their wedding reception,
where I went they never
have live bands anymore,
I don't know why no one hires live
bands anymore, what's going on?
And I got a teenaged
son in high school.
He has never been to a dance
that had a live band performing,
it's always a DJ playing.
Well anyway, if you provide
music at a wedding reception,
you've got to play
the couple's song.
The song brought them together,
and I think many of us have songs
like that too, that
brought us together.
That I'll go further.
I will say that many of
us would not be here today
if our parents have not heard at a
certain point in time the right song
that created the right mood.
You know, I was saying music
was technology for people
who didn't have semi-conductors.
Well before they had those
little blue pills, and you needed
to create the right mood,
what did you rely on?
It was music.
It was music, and there's a
lot of evidence to back this.
You know, I just read this morning,
just this morning I read a new study
that showed that when people
listen to music together,
the hormone oxytocin is released in
their brain and it creates a sense
of trust and bonding
between the two of them.
So the idea that the love
song brings people together,
this is not just a wild
idea, this is body chemistry.
Once again, music is a technology.
It makes things happen.
So I decided I would write
the history of love songs.
And one of the first things
I found that surprised me is
that no one had written a book
on the history of the love song.
There was not a single book on
the history of the love song.
There were books about
specific kinds of love songs,
like troubadour songs or disco songs
or whatever, but there was no book
to cover the full servile,
now this surprise me
because the most popular
kind of song
for the last thousand
years is been a love song,
for a thousand years the love song
has been the most popular kind
of song and there's
no book about it,
and I found that there were reasons.
First of all, it's a very
difficult subject to encompass.
That's why it took me so
many years to write the book,
in such a difficult subject
because to tell the history
of the love song you need to
understand the history of marriage,
courtship, romance, sexuality,
you need to understand there
were legal issues involved
in these things.
There was censorship,
there were prohibitions.
It's a very complex subject.
But there was another reason
why scholars do not write
about love songs.
It's a simple one.
They are embarrassed by these songs.
They are ashamed of these songs.
When I would tell people,
what I was writing about,
I'd get an interesting response.
You know, I mean, the other
people that are music writers
and there's some in
the audience today.
And they would call out to me Ted,
what's your next book
going to be about?
And I would say, "I'm writing
a book about love songs",
and they would give me this look.
And they wouldn't say anything
but you could tell what
they were thinking.
That's a wimpy thing to write about.
You're going to write about
those sappy love songs.
They would have more respect for me
if I was writing about heavy metal,
the 12 tone row, but love songs?
Yet I know that if you saw their
albums, if you saw their playlist,
it's full of love songs,
just like all
of our play lists are
filled with love songs.
I know these love songs.
You know these love songs.
We all know these love songs.
We all know the words,
200 of love songs.
Don't we? And when we're in the car
alone and no one can see us and it's
on the radio, we will
leave and sing along,
just look in your rearview mirror,
you can see people
[inaudible] love songs.
But were ashamed of them.
It's interesting there's
a music critic I
like named Dave Hickey
and he said something.
He said 90% of music is about
love but music critics want
to write about the other10%.
Ninety percent of the music
out there is about love
but music critics want to
write about the other 10%.
And I think that's true.
Where did we get this shame?
Now Darwin would have told us,
there's nothing to
be embarrassed here.
Darwin thought that all
music was a love song.
He thought the sole purpose
of music was courtship.
If you read his book "The
Descent of Man", he spends a lot
of time talking about music.
And he believes music is part
of sexual selection,
brings couples together.
It's the sole biological
evolutionary purpose
of music in Darwin's mind.
But you know, when I first read
Darwin about this, I was unconvinced
because if you read it, all
he talks about is bird songs.
That he spends more time writing
about bird music than human music.
And he doesn't even mention
gorillas, chimps, monkeys,
you know this hierarchy,
all our closer relatives.
He just skips them completely.
And for a good reason because
they don't have love songs.
There are no gorilla love
songs or something like that.
There's a guy, Leonard
Williams, a musician,
he's father of the classical
guitars, John Williams,
not the film composer, not the
Star Wars, not that John Williams
but it was a classical
guitarist John Williams.
His dad Leonard Williams was a great
musician and also lived with monkeys
for many years, was
an expert on monkeys.
And he had the privilege of
being able to hear monkeys
on a regular basis fornicating.
I perhaps should say he
had a dubious privilege
of hearing monkeys
fornicating on a daily basis.
And he said "they do not sing',
there is no singing
in monkey courtship.
They might grumble or growl or roar
or murmur but there is no singing.
So I was very skeptical of Darwin.
I was very skeptical with Darwin
because I thought his
reasoning didn't hold up.
But you know in the
last five, ten years,
a lot of new evidences
come out to support Darwin.
And it's all about body chemistry,
you know this study I just talked
about the other-- at
the beginning of my talk
about the oxytocin release,
you know, the hormones.
We now know involved
in sexual behavior
and courtship are the
same ones correlated
with musical receptivity
and musical talent.
There's a growing body of
evidences I write about in my book.
I'm not going to go at length
here but there's a growing body
of evidences that to some extent,
survival of the fittest is
survival of the most musical.
So, I have come to accept
that Darwin is right.
I have come to accept that.
But you know, I should've
figured that out long ago.
I should've figured out long ago
that music was linked
to sexual behavior.
All you need to do is read the
biographies of these rock musicians.
You know, you read about
Mick Jagger who had had what,
3000 sexual partners and Gene
Simmons actually keeps a list,
the singer of "Kiss".
Who knows what he looks like
behind that kind of make up
but he's actually kept a list
of the 5800 and whatever women
that he slept with, whatever.
So I should've figured
this out long ago
that there is some connection here.
And there have been studies
now to document this.
This is an interesting study.
This was done a few years ago.
They had a guy go up to random
women on the street in France
and ask them for their phone number.
He would ask them for
their phone number.
You look so lovely, which I
don't do a good a French accent
but would you give
me your phone number?
What he found was that 14% of the
women would give a total stranger
who approached them on
the street a phone number.
The next day, the same guy
went to the same neighborhood,
same question only now he's
carrying a guitar case.
Do you think that shames
the results?
>> Yes.
>> Day one, 14%.
Day two, 31%.
[ Laughter ]
I see some guy writing down back.
This is useful information.
You're glad you came out on
a cold night to learn this.
Here's the best part of this day.
The third day they tested the
same guy, same neighborhood,
only this time he's
carrying an athletic bag
like he just worked out.
Only 9% of the women gave
him their phone number.
So guys, if you think
by working out,
you'd become more attractive
to women, forget it.
Don't go to the gym,
learn to play the guitar
or actually just buy a guitar.
Just hold the case, you
don't even need to learn.
There was another study done,
a very similar one based
on Facebook friend request.
And in this study,
a guy sent a woman
who was a complete stranger
a Facebook friend request.
And what he found was that 9%
of women would accept a
Facebook friend request
from a total stranger.
But when the picture of him
in his profile show him playing
guitar, it went up to 28%.
So once again, Darwin
was probably right.
There is some connection between
music and sexual selection
that we only, did we understand.
We only do we understand now.
But we're ashamed of it.
Where do we get this shame?
I think the shame came
from the Romans.
I think our embarrassment about long
songs came from the ancient Romans.
You know, C. S. Lewis
wrote a book in the 1930s.
Now, you probably know who C.
S. Lewis from his Narnia stories
which have been made into
these blockbuster movies.
We may know his writings on religion
but C.S. Lewis was also a
great scholar, taught at Oxford
who was an expert in
medieval literature.
He wrote a book in the 30s
called the "Allegory of Love".
And in this book, he makes
an amazing caima [phonetic].
He says, there was no
romance in ancient times.
He said, the Romans did not
know about romantic love.
That's extraordinary
because the word romance come
from the word Roman.
So, if the Romans didn't
know about romance, who did?
But C.S. Lewis know the
romantic love was not discovered
until the troubadours did and
it rounded up in the century.
There was no romantic love
in the world before that.
And then he goes on to
make other strange claims.
He says even today, now you got
to realize he's talking in 1936.
He said even today, there is
no romance in India, Japan,
he lists these countries where
according to him there's no romance.
So these are extraordinary
things to say.
They're extraordinary things
to say and I disagree with much
of what C.S. Lewis says here,
but there's a grain of truth.
There's a grain of truth if
you sift through the evidence.
I've spent a lot of time
studying ancient musical practices
and ancient culture
and I can tell you,
the Romans did know
about romantic love.
They did know about
it but they hated it.
They feared it.
They felt that falling in
love was like an illness.
love was like insanity.
No sane person would want to have
that helpless feeling
of falling in love.
The Romans like to conquer and when
you fall in love, you are conquered.
Now they understood that were
benefits to having a good marriage,
particularly marrying
into a powerful family.
They understood the
benefits of sexual union.
They understood the advantages
of having a soulmate and people
that would be your
partners for life.
But this idea of falling in love,
they feared, particularly for men.
It was unmanly.
You can read what Cicero and Seneca,
and people talked about love.
And they talked about
love songs too.
They were worried about
these love songs.
And the lover in these
love songs is often held
up as a figure of ridicule.
Most of the love songs that have
survived from ancient Rome come
from the Roman comedies
and the lover
in these comedies is
someone you will laugh at.
Falling in love was shameful
and I believe we even
inherited that to some extent.
And even when you get into
the era of Christianity,
it doesn't get any
better for the love song.
For the first 1000 years of
Christianity, the church tried
to eradicate the love song.
The church tried to
eradicate the love song.
And the best way of proving
this is like you go to Scotland
and say show me love songs in
Europe in the vernacular languages,
not in Latin and Greek but the
language of the common people
in France, Italy, Spain, England.
Show me the love songs in
the vernacular language
from the first 1000
years of Christianity.
And they will not be
able to find one.
You can't find one that has
survived in its entirety.
Well we'll get a few lines.
You know, someone will be
doing an illuminated manuscript
and they'll be writing the epistle
of Paul and the book of revelation.
And in the margin, you'll find a
few lines of a dirty love song.
I mean, you'll never
get the whole song.
You just get a couple of lines.
So do we surmise that there were no
love songs among the common people
of Europe?
It was the opposite.
The experts on this
believed there were tens
of thousands of loves songs.
They just haven't survived.
How do we know they existed?
The best evidence is from the--
how frequently the church
attacked and criticized them?
Priests were always giving
sermons attacking love songs
and usually they were
singing-- singling out women.
And so, we got to stop these women
from singing these love songs.
And church councils would
issues proclamations,
women have to stop
singing love songs,
nothing more dangerous
than these love songs.
In third century, the pope
prohibited these love songs.
In the eight century, Charlemagne
passed a law making these love songs
illegal even as late as Abelard,
and when the late medieval stage
then he was the most famous
theologian to this date but
he also sang these love songs.
We are told that everybody knew
his love songs and could sing them
but not one of them had survived.
So the church tried to get rid
of all of these love songs.
In fact, are these books,
these are fascinating books.
They're called penitentials.
The penitential was a guide to
a priest hearing confessions.
So if someone came to you with
a confession and said, "Father,
I stole my neighbor's chicken" or
I lusted after my neighbor's wife.
The penitential would tell the
priest what the pennant should be.
OK. If you say, five "Our fathers"
three "Hail Mary's" you're OK.
And these penitentials are our
best source of information.
Actually, about the
sex lives of people
in medieval times,
this is a side note.
What sexual sin do you think
is mentioned most frequently
in these books?
Sex with animals.
That is the most frequently
mentioned sex.
It was [inaudible] but anyway,
three of these penitentials
mentioned love songs and say
that singing love song is a
sin that cannot be forgiven.
It cannot be forgiven.
Using that love song, you're
going to burn in hellfire.
Now, you go up with that sheep
and the goat, we can handle that
but you can't sing these love songs.
It's extraordinary.
So you get an idea for 1000
years, the church tried
to eradicate the love song.
But finally, the love song
came out into the open.
Came out into the open with the
troubadours and why is that?
It's because now, the king
was singing love songs.
The nobility was singing love songs.
You know, the inventor
of the troubadour love
song we're told was a duke.
So what do you do when the
duke starts singing love song?
So the church lost this battle.
The love songs come out into the
open and the nobility in the south
of France is given credit
for inventing the western
love song but did they really?
Did they really?
What about all these women that
were chastised by the church
for 1000 years or even
more interestingly,
there's a whole chapter of this
that's never been written before.
And I got a whole stack of books
at home when the troubadours,
none of them mentioned the female
slave singers in the Muslim world.
Who 100, 200 years before the
troubadours were singing love songs
almost identical to the ones
that were supposedly invented
in the south of France
in the 11th century.
In the Muslim world, female slave
singers would sing about love.
The epicenter was Baghdad.
These songs spread through
North Africa and then
after the Muslim conquest to
Spain, they came into Spain.
And then, finally just a few
miles away in the south of France,
the nobles start signing
almost the exact same songs
that these female slave singers
in the Muslim world were doing.
And historians have
not picked up on this.
They've ignored this.
They give the credit to the nobles
but they forget this whole
hidden history of the love song.
And all of a sudden, when you see
these things start making sense,
the king is singing love songs,
the nobility is singing love song
and they're talking about
being a slave to love.
Well how can the king be a slave?
But it starts to make
sense when you realize
that the people they
took these songs
from were actually slaves,
were actually slaves.
You would be surprised
how much of the history
of the love song was
created by slaves.
You go back to ancient
Rome, you remember I talked
about these Roman comedies, that
music was all played by slaves.
The music was written by slaves.
Often, they would have
performances and the slave would get
on stage and sing the song.
Because it was not respectable
for a Roman citizen to sing.
You remember that story about
Nero fiddling while Rome burned?
You know what a scandal it was?
The scandal wasn't that Rome burned,
because you can't stop a fire,
the scandal was that the
emperor was playing music.
It was scandalous.
So the innovations and love songs
in ancient times came from slaves.
The innovations in the middle ages
came from slaves in the underclass.
Now what about more recent times?
What about more recent times?
What about United States?
I'll ask you a question, what
was the most popular love song
in America in 1850?
By far, the most popular love song
in America in 1850 was "Oh Susanna".
[Singing] Oh Susanna,
oh don't you cry for me.
Because I come from Alabama
with the banjo on my knee.
That's right, written
by Stephen Foster.
White guy from the north.
But he was imitating the
slave songs of the south,
and those slaves didn't have
access to music publishers
and copyright, but
Stephen Foster did.
And this was a great
innovation in the love song.
Came out of the slave community
then fast forward to later times.
And I would say the most important
innovations in the love songs
in the 20th century came from
the descendants of slaves.
In the year 1900, if you
had gone experts on music,
people who really knew music in the
year 1900 and ask them what is going
to be the future of popular
music in the 20th century?
Predict the future of popular
music in the 20 century,
what would they have said?
What they would've said is
the exciting popular music
in 1900 is all coming from Europe.
You got to go to the cabarets in
Berlin, the cabarets in Paris.
The music halls of London, people
are saying these sexy songs
and controversial songs and
they're filled with satire
and humor and they're daring.
They're bold, they're gay.
Meanwhile in the United States,
the hit songs in 1900 were boring.
You know, I've studied the love
songs of 19th century America
and no one ever kisses
in those songs.
No one ever hugs.
It's just I feel a great
sentiment for you my darling.
I mean, they're the most
boring songs you can imagine.
There was all this exciting stuff
happening in the Paris cabarets
and anyone who was smart in the
year 1900 would saying Europe is the
future of popular music, but
they would've been wrong.
And why would they have been wrong?
Because they didn't understand the
contributions that would be made
by the descendants of slaves
by the African-American
community in the 20th century.
With jazz and the blues, all these
new ways of singing about love birds
that no one had seen before,
and it was even more exciting
that what was happening
in France and Berlin
and all those other places.
And so the United States
dominated popular music
in the 20th century as we all know.
And it was because the innovations
in love songs again came
from the underclass.
What about more recently,
in our own lifetimes,
where have the innovations
in love songs come from?
The ruling class or the underclass?
What about rock and roll?
Let's talk about Elvis from
the poorest state in the union.
From Elvis Presley,
he learned his music
from the blues singers
in Mississippi.
What about the British innovation?
The Beatles, the British innovation?
The British innovation come
from Buckingham palace.
He was in the docks in Liverpool.
Once again, it was the poor,
the underclass, the outsider.
What has been the most
shocking change in love songs
in the last 30 or 40 years?
Got to be hip-hop, don't you think?
That come from the ruling class?
It's a pretty easy
question to answer.
This is the hidden
history of the love song.
Eventually, all this music is
accepted by the upper class.
Eventually all of this was
controlled by the White House.
Eventually rock and
roll was mainstream,
eventually hip-hop will
be mainstream as well.
But when the new innovations in love
songs come out, they always come
from the Bohemian, from slave, from
the underclass, from the outsider.
And I think as we peer to the
future, we should expect the same.
There will be more innovations
in love songs in the future.
It will continue to change.
There will be new ways
of singing about love.
There will be revolutionary
new ways of singing about love.
And they will come from the
place we least expected.
It will come from the outsider, from
the bohemian from the underclass.
The songs will come and
they will change our lives.
Thank you very much, I'll
now answer questions.
[ Applause ]
Anybody have a question?
So microphone will be going
around if you have a question.
>> I'm just wondering if you could
just give a very general definition
of what you mean by love song?
>> Ted Gioia: This is a very, again,
it's a very complicated question.
Let me give you an example.
The oldest love songs in my opinion
come from ancient Mesopotamia.
And they were involved in
these fertility rights.
And there was this thing called
the sacred marriage ritual.
And the sacred marriage ritual
every year, the king had to have sex
with the Goddess so
the crops would grow.
The crops would grow, the
kingdom would be prosperous.
Now, this is difficult, you know,
guys know how difficult it is
to get a date on a Saturday night,
but how do you get a
date with the Goddess.
You know, and this is not easy.
So the high priestess had to
step in and perform this ritual
with the king and the scholars
debate endlessly whether they--
do they actually have sex
and this is the debate.
They go off to the temple, the
king and the high priestess
and the sacred marriage ritual
takes place and then the crops grow.
And now these songs, their
songs that are associated
with the sacred marriage ritual
which I call the first love songs,
but a lot of people read
these songs and say this isn't
about love, it's just about sex.
You can't call that a love
song, it's just a sex song.
But I will point out, people say the
same things today about Miley Cyrus,
Madonna, you know,
Beyonce, whatever.
So I'm going to-- in many
ways, we just come full circle.
We're back to ancient Mesopotamia.
My view was I define
the love song broadly.
Songs that bring people together in
various romantic ways and some ways,
sometimes just sexual
ways, it's very hard
to distinguish the difference
between a love and sex in a song,
but it's hard in life, isn't it?
I mean now, we've all had
relationship with [inaudible].
Now what kind of relationship
am I actually in, you know?
So, you know.
So I didn't try to, you
know, slice hairs in half.
I took a broad view and anything
that brings people together,
even if it's an ancient
king and a high priestess
in a sacred marriage ritual,
I call it a love song.
Yes?
>> What is it about--
>> Ted Gioia: You know, speak
to the microphone, here.
>> What is it about music
that is so evocative?
I mean it's not just love songs.
I mean, you can hear a
song from 30 years ago
and basically you are
and know what you hear.
So now it's serious
[inaudible] and you can see
that yes, it was in 1967.
And it's not necessarily
positive, you know,
it might be something
from a sad event.
But I think there must be
something actually between music
and memory here, I mean
I'm thinking that, so.
>> Ted Gioia: No, you're
absolutely right.
I remember this song I
heard on my first date.
And it's an awful song.
I hate this, but every time we
hear on the radio, I know that song
on my first date, you know.
And so, you know, you're [inaudible]
just really think in our memory.
And we respond to this
music and it is one
of the grandest mysteries
of physiology.
I mean for example,
just take something
as simple as dancing to a beat.
Every society does it.
But you know, no animal does it,
you cannot teach a dog
to dance to the beat.
You can't teach a horse, you know,
it's just very interesting,
for us it's instinctive.
Now, neuroscientists are
starting to unlock this.
And they're finding all sorts of
interesting things about brainwaves,
body chemistry, parts of
the mind that process music.
And I think overtime, we will
eventually learn more about this.
But I do suspect there's going to be
something that's always mysterious.
But you're right, I do
believe we respond in music
in a way that is magical.
That's one of the reasons
why I hate to just think
that a music is entertainment.
You know, music is magical, it's
transformative, it's change agent.
It changes our lives.
We're not just passive listeners.
I'm just going to give
you an example.
Tia De Nora is a sociologist.
She did a study a few years
ago about what happens
when you bring someone over to
your home for a dinner date?
You bring in someone
over to your home,
they've never been
in your place before.
You've invited them over for dinner.
You're thinking romance,
what do you do?
Well, the first you do is you clean
up your place, I know
you're all slugs.
So the first you're going to do is--
Then the second thing you worry
about, what food am I going to cook?
You know, for me this is a panic,
you know, I have to do take out.
It's going to be like
Chinese, or pizza, you know.
But then the third thing is music.
The third thing is music and
she documented this talking
to people how they
choose what music to play
when someone is coming
over for a dinner date?
So it shows you that the-- we're
not just passive listeners,
we believe in this magic of music.
I feel sorry for these people
that are really in the hip-hop,
and then someone's coming
over in, oh I got these--
I'll go about these bulgur lyrics.
You know, you got to go, I got
to buy a Frank Sinatra album,
you know what I, you know.
So we, in our hearts we
believe in the magic of music.
I believe scientists
will unlock some of it,
but some of it will
always be in this strand
of beautiful mystery,
a beautiful mystery.
Any other questions?
>> Hi. Yes, I've always
thought of the Beatles and much
of the British innovation
as an outgrowth
of the great American songbook,
does everyone agree or disagree?
>> Ted Gioia: Well yeah, you know,
the people at that time thought
that the Beatles were such a
radical break, but not really.
If you go back when the Beatles
run the Ed Sullivan Show,
the Beatles run the Ed Sullivan
Show, and I've actually done a count
of the songs, they played 80
% of them were love songs.
And it went really-- that outrage
just say I want to hold your hand?
Was that really such an
outrageous thing to say?
So you're right, and in many ways,
a lot of those songs showed a lot
of this craftsmanship
that you've [inaudible].
So yeah, it wasn't as big
a break as people think.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
There was some connection, but if
you take Glen and McCartney try
to figure out what influenced
them is a wide range of things.
I do think McCartney
was listening to a lot
of music hall songs in London.
Here's a song like when
I'm 64, it's almost ready
for the music hall stage in
London, but I believe, yeah.
In fact, when you and I
before-- we've got on tonight,
we talked about Nat King Cole.
There's a case to be
made that McCartney song
"Yesterday" is a restatement of a
Nat King Cole song he heard that was
in his dad's record
collection when he was a kid.
So I mean, the connections there
went deeper the most people realize.
Yes, any other question?
There was someone back there
and I'll get to you next.
>> The history of the love song
and I'm curious, in this country,
Western tends to be about,
as you took the [inaudible].
And we're not deemed-- I don't
know if that's considered blues
or if you've been able to
track down that style of music
or something like that came from.
And if you see that
in other cultures,
you talked about male Americans
or things in Europe, possibly Asia
and there's a similar country
western style of love song.
>> Ted Gioia: You know,
it's interesting.
When I was in my 20s, I got
a scholarship that allowed me
to go study at Oxford for two years.
So I'm an American--
Most of my life,
I grew up in South Central
L.A. So you bring me
to Oxford, it's like culture shock.
And I just-- People there-- I
would say, why do you do this?
This is-- Because we've
always done it that way.
Well that's not a reason.
You can't say and, you know.
But what I found, I was
amazed how many people
in Oxford were listening
to country music.
How many people, particularly the
people that worked in the college
that weren't students, but the
people that sort of like served
at the dining hall or whatever?
And there was this message that
country music spoke to them
in a way that I had not expected.
It was very surprising
and you find--
if you take some sappy company
song like "Achy Breaky Heart".
That was like the number
hit in Finland, Denmark.
I mean, it's amazing
how this music travels
to places you don't think it would.
And I believe there's
a reason for this.
How do I try-- let
me articulate this.
And I think it explains a lot of
what's happening in music nowadays.
I believe that music today
and the love song today more
than at any point in history is
embedded in people's fantasy life.
And it expresses not so
much the life they have
but the life they wish they had.
And let me give you another example,
there are all of these
retro jazz albums now,
like Lady Gaga is doing an
album on with Tony Bennett
and Queen Latifah is
doing with [inaudible].
Everyone is doing this
retro jazz stuff.
And I know people like
the old jazz songs.
I don't think it's just that.
I think they like the romance.
They look at this old
jazz and they associate it
with people getting dressed up and
going out on romantic evenings out.
And here's something.
I've got a son who is in college.
And as far as I can tell,
his friends in college
do not go on dates.
The younger generation
does not go on dates.
Now, how sad is that?
Now, it's just interesting.
They had a lot of sex
as far as I can tell.
And that's the exact opposite.
When I was in college, you know,
that getting the sex part
was the hard part to get.
But going on a date
was easy, you know.
It is flip flop now where
there are a lot of people
out there hungry for romance.
A lot of people in the younger
generation I believe are hungering
for romance.
And that's why they go into
this country western music
or these old jazz songs
because the romantic ethos
of that music expresses
something they want to know
like it's hard to find nowadays.
That's a controversial view
but that's what I believe.
He's got a question here, so let's--
and then we'll take two more
questions and then wrap up.
Yup?
>> I read about the history of jazz,
what do you think of the future
of jazz in terms form and
its place in the larger seam
of things in the music world.
>> Ted Gioia: I've got a book coming
out in May called how
to listen to jazz.
And I focus a lot on that issue.
Because I hear people all
the time say jazz is dead.
I must have seen 20 articles in
the media over the last five years,
the headline is jazz is dead.
And I don't believe that at
all, I believe jazz is fine.
And now jazz is hurting
from an economic standpoint.
Because they never put it on TV,
they never put it on the radio.
It's-- The coverage in all
the media has disappeared.
And so, it's not surprising to me
that jazz musicians are
struggling economically
because this global mass
entertainment industry
that dominates everything
has marginalized jazz.
But, if you actually
dig deeply into it
and I listen to new jazz everyday.
During the course of a typical year,
I've listened to around a
thousand newly-released albums.
This is the first day-- This year
I have listened to a new album.
Before I got in a plane yesterday,
I've listened to four albums
during the course of the day.
And then most of the
albums have been released
in the last two or three weeks.
So I try to keep my hand on
the pulse of music today.
There are maybe music critics
who listen to more new music
than I do, but I haven't met them.
I will say, if you dig
deeply into the music,
there are great things happening.
There's actually more
good music happening now
than ever before, but it is hidden.
It is hidden.
I will-- Every week, I
will hear some great album
and almost every instance,
it's something that's not going
to get any radio [inaudible].
Because it doesn't
fit into the format.
And someone is not
going to get on TV
because they don't
fit into the format.
So I would say there's a
lot of great jazz happening.
Unfortunately, you have to dig it
out because the media
is hiding it from you.
And I'll have a lot more
about that on my next book.
OK. This guy knows more
about jazz than I do.
So I can be--
>> Pull on me.
Ted, thank you for our terrific talk
and could you share some
your thoughts about the role
of Jewish-American composers
in establishing the body
of American love songs?
>> Ted Gioia: Well,
they had a huge role.
They had I mean, because
if you look at the people
that really pioneered the American
love song, it tended to be people
like the Gershwin Brothers,
George and Ira,
Irving Berlin, you
just go on and on.
Harold Arnold was the-- it was
the Jewish songwriters who tapped
into the African-American
jazz stuff.
And I understood that
they mixed it in with many
of their own musical traditions
and there's a huge amount
of Jewish music that filtered into
popular music or [inaudible] music,
but you can hear that filtering in.
And it's interesting
even, take Cole Porter,
he was one of the few songwriters
there who wasn't Jewish.
And he was having a conversation
with someone once and he said,
"I'm going to write Jewish songs".
That's right, I'm going
to write Jewish.
That was his idea how to
write a love song in America.
So it was this extraordinary,
but really, it was--
I'm going to go to this whole thing
where I say the outsider
has more freedom to sing
about new ways of love
than the inside.
If you are a member of the ruling
class, you have to be respectable.
You're a member of the ruling class,
you have to watch everything
you do or say.
And so the members of the ruling
class are never good at tapping
into new ways of singing about love.
It's always someone on the fringes.
So you get these children
of Jewish immigrants hanging
out with jazz musicians in
Harlem, I'm not surprised at all
that they came up with innovation.
Because they didn't have this--
That's the sense of
shame I'm talking about.
They had this more-- a
greater way to experiment.
So yeah, we wouldn't
have the modern love song
without the Jewish-American
promoters.
One last question?
>> Hi Ted, great discussion.
I had-- my question to you
was regarding, you'd mentioned
about how music, a love music
came from slaves and primarily
in the Muslim culture and how that
kind of affected certain things.
But I'm curious in your
research, was there any--
did anything come up with regards
to African, sort of music and--
because I grew up in Africa
and a lot of the love songs
when I was coming up, you'd
never knew them as love songs.
I didn't know what they meant.
You know, adults are just singing
and you just kind of sing along
but you didn't know what-- I
thinking about older, you're like,
oh, that was what they
were talking about.
But, in any case, I'm curious
to see, to hear from you
in your research, was there any, you
know, correlation with, you know,
Africa and African-American slaves,
you know, that kind of cycle?
>> Ted Gioia: If you go back in the
historical sources, first of all,
the great tragedy is this-- the
scarcity of historical sources.
Because one of the great questions
is if you had grown around Africa
in the year 100, 1200, 1400
what music would you have heard?
And the sources are not good
ones, you can read what Herodotus,
a Greek said there's a great
book by a guy named Mungo Park.
He was an African traveler
and he went--
was exploring the interior Africa,
this would have been 500 years
ago, 400 to 500 years ago.
And he was sold into
slavery in Africa.
And was traveling from community
to community and eventually,
two years later, he got back to
the cost to a European settlement
in tatters of clothing and with
some paperwork he had written,
everything he had seen
in those two years.
And it's called-- Travels with
Mungo Park, and this book,
he encounters music everywhere
and all kinds of music.
It's extraordinary.
And he's just, wow.
And there are other just these
little snippets of information,
we have for example if you go
back in the late medieval period,
there's a writing from a Christian
source about an African musician
who had traveled into Spain
and was singing a love song
that they found shocking
and scandalous.
There are paintings from Spain
in the late medieval period
that will show bands playing and
there will be black musicians
and white musicians in the painting
and the black musician is sort
of the center of prominence where
the leader of the band would be.
So you have these, you have all
these little snippets of clues
and you'd love to have a bigger
picture where the preponderance
of evidence suggest that there was
an extraordinary musical culture
in Africa throughout
this whole period,
and a lot of it was focused on love.
A lot of them was focused on love.
And when I say these
Muslim slave singers,
I have to say these slaves
were not Muslims themselves
for the more part.
These were people from conquest.
So a lot of them were from parts
of Africa, Ethiopia or whatever,
and they were the innovators
in the love songs.
So even though when I call
them Muslim slaves singers,
that's misleading, in many ways,
a lot of them were Africans
who were bringing their own
musical traditions together
and singing these songs.
So that's the history but still
that's not been adequately written.
It still has not been
adequately written,
but there's a rich
history there to be found.
Any other questions?
I'm happy to answer
afterwards or sign books.
Thank you for coming.
You've been one [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the library of congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.